getting in and out of allegiant stadium
has been a real hassle for a lot of
people and now you're going to add the
new vaccine requirement in order to get
into the raiders game on top of that
could make wait times even longer
victoria saha joining us now live on
what you can try to do to make the
process quicker and easier if you're
going to the game victoria
denise the countdown is on but if before
you get through those doors you need to
make sure that you have your clear app
ready to go it's just a new system the
raiders are using to make sure their
fans are vaccinated
as we get ready for monday now is the
perfect time to make a game plan so you
can get in and out of allegion stadium
hassle free first thing is to have your
vaccine information ready you don't just
stop at uploading your covet vaccination
information into the clear up you need
to make sure the light turns green
giving you the clear to enter the
stadium the clear app only accepts the
moderna johnson and johnson and the
pfizer if you got any other vaccine you
need to make sure you go to the
alternate screening process that's going
to be in lot b and if you haven't gotten
vaccinated at all you can still do it on
game day the vaccine clinics are going
to be right here in lot c
parking has been an issue commissioner
michael naft says there are more than 13
thousand parking spots available around
the stadium the more you pay for a
parking pass the closer you are to the
stadium some right on site some a little
bit further out to valley view into the
strip hacienda bridge will also close
for cars at noon you are encouraged to
get there at least three hours earlier
the alternate screening applies to
people who are partially vaccinated or
who have a minor that's 12 years or
older and if you still have trouble with
the clear app representatives from the
company will be on site on game day
reporting live from allegion stadium
victoria saha 8 news now
three hours before game time as denise
pointed out that's more than an
international flight we checked for
raiders ticket prices online
ticketmaster has tickets for monday
night's game 186 dollars a person that
was the cheapest from there they go up
to about 220. stubhub has tickets
starting at 200 bucks